that's right with the Super Bowl comes
Super Bowl movie trailers as you can
tell my voice is a bit hoarse because I
am from the Pacific Northwest and I was
watching the Super Bowl thus here I am
but of the movie trailers I saw I got a
touch on transformers 4 or transformers
age of extinction because I have a
love-hate thing with transformers I
loved that I hated it enough to start my
youtube channel transformers 2 was the
one that got us here now Here I am so
I'm gonna touch on the Super Bowl
trailer spot for transformers for a lot
of big rollout you see Megatron actually
turns into a gun I think it's funny that
finally in the fourth movie Megatron
does what he actually did in the cartoon
I know among other lore he's turned into
a lot of other [ __ ] too I'm just saying
as I knew he turned into a gun and she
does michaelbay explosions that looks
like 4th of July fireworks Michael Bay
it's not that you use explosions for
everything I'm just saying your
explosions look like fireworks that's
why people hate them funny Mark
Wahlberg's in this movie now not Shia
LaBeouf and then this really attractive
girl screaming for him like dad she's in
a cage or something because the
Decepticons are like we need a hot chick
again let's steal her that was like who
is this girl and I looked her up she's
the girl from last airbender all grown
up now again did another hot chick who
can't act in a Michael Bay movie par for
the course for the first time around but
then I thought wait a minute she was in
last airbender Mark Wahlberg wasn't
happening here's what's going on but
Decepticons are trying to take out
everyone who has been in a bad Shyamalan
movie in which case I say hey who are
the Autobots to deny us that and then
the end of this trailer
knocking live a bill do the cheesiest
most childish part of me we're talking
the part of me that still goes yeah when
I see the Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
morph or some [ __ ] I don't know no no
saying there's still watch Power Rangers
it makes me happy you see the Dinobots
not only do you see the Dinobots you see
Optimus Prime on the back of Grimlock me
Grimlock stronger not only is Optimus
Prime riding Grimlock it's like a sword
and a shield or some [ __ ] nothing is
more awesome than that nothing I can
think of except for maybe a good movie
but if we're not gonna get a good movie
at least give me Optimus Prime riding a
robotic Tyrannosaurus Rex with horns
you think Optimus Prime has a bumper
sticker when he's the truck that says my
other ride is Grimlock I think he should
so transformers age of extinction I'm
just saying it's gonna be cheesy it's
gonna be hokey it's gonna be par for the
course Michael base yet but if it
tase me with Optimus Prime riding a
Tyrannosaurus Rex with a sword
well the Decepticons are rounding up
everybody from the Bad Shyamalan movies
I don't know maybe I can be entertained
so the transformers age of extinction
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know God my voice
is going I was happy the Seahawks won
there were a lot of plays that happened
in this Super Bowl that warranted
Seahawks fans jumping up it's screaming
like idiots as one of them and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more